[Music]
in thug life news flash oh that's not
very thug life
yeah oh let's deal with the glasses
there works submitted by green beans
don't green bananas I'm so sorry what
happened there dude anybody else smell
blueberries and copper so Korean parents
are hiring thugs to stop school bullies
that's not get hella career dude that's
a really good idea you won't miss it
with a mic yeah but then it shows them
they're gonna be employed after school's
done this what who do you think that
kids work that's true there's a job path
the Korean bullying is pretty [ __ ]
harsh though like it's they do it out of
love first so could you imagine how bad
it is to really bully somebody
well there's there there's a hazing
bullying there's the actual bullying and
the the borderline abuse bullying and
there's like different levels that's my
mom
I forgot what what movie I was watching
but there's a reoccurring theme that you
see in like female bullying in Korea
where if there's this girl that's like
hot but a lot of guys like they'll like
[ __ ] cut the girls hair Oh cut her up
with like razor blades or some [ __ ] that
was like an exaggeration but my mom said
like that did happen like they like when
she was a school girl yeah like they
would lock up like a really pretty girl
that was popular with the boys and they
would try to maim the girl just be like
branding her like they were like like
they pull her hair out pull the girl's
hair out like beat her up and [ __ ] like
razor blades though yeah well that was
in the film I'm saying like oh this is
it that girls will rip each other's hair
like they would rip the girl's [ __ ]
hair out of [ __ ] so I don't know so I
know that black how far it went yeah let
me try to make her a plea yeah doesn't
sound too far-fetched cuz like some of
the Asian chicks that I knew that baned
yeah what do [ __ ] like that oh [ __ ] so
there's there are girls that are just
[ __ ] gangster as [ __ ] they're all
gangs yeah like don't do like girl hate
[ __ ] like you can't be so hot like you
know cuz I'm ugly but that's like an
extreme North Korean style form of
bullying yeah so multiple companies are
offering different packages for these
bullies organized it's ranging from four
hundred and fifty dollars to one
thousand seven
ninety dollars a day would you like a
beatdown sir
four kids come the intimidation package
where they just scare them a little bit
and they don't actually hurt oh you guys
are playing but they're really caught so
is the uncle package man in his 30s or
40s will reportedly walk with the
student to and from school and sternly
warned bullies off yeah I'm gonna get
you beat up more I have like an uncle be
like now you kids but or not yes like
Korean gangster style that's different
then yeah they're tattooed men must be
like a Joe Pesci or some [ __ ] okay
Tenshi afoot he's got the speed and he's
gonna he's like gets in your hitbox real
quick debido to protect my kids there's
also an evidence package that offers an
upgrade where the uncle will film the
bullies in action and present the
findings to the school and then he will
also threaten to make the video public
if there's no facts so that's the best
package right there yeah how was that
cost I don't know they don't like the
private detective kind of [ __ ] give me a
range of price which was 450 were like
thousand bucks like 1800 that's a pretty
good deal blackmail package yeah it's
the blackmail package the executive
package so they [ __ ] finally couldn't
chop their [ __ ] legs off they make
you eat your own parents package that I
have is chaperone package where it will
be a more high-profile tactic of
visiting the parents or the bully's
parents at their workplace and publicly
shame them Oh
that's a big meal Wow going through the
parents yeah at their place of work and
Karine already sounds hello aggressive
so I can imagine them just yelling at
the [ __ ] do it do it
no like yell at the parent the bully
pain yeah you know kid yeah yeah she
Bible buddy
she bar secured [ __ ] like that you know
and I just picture a bouncing cigarette
[Music]
every time I watch like a green Phil
yeah Andy they fight I'm like when do
they inhale like it's just a long
stretch of like my character coach are
oh yeah the sticker channel are you
inhaling through your nose well like you
speak and it just goes out like this I
just saying all the [ __ ] my parents you
say to be good that's pretty cool a thug
Thug package yeah well so a lot of
parents right now are really afraid for
their kids because they're saying that
suicide is the most common cause of
death among young Koreans between the
ages of 15 and 24 so stuff and like
bullying is just getting out of control
where there's no one really trying to
crack down on the bullying so now
parents are taking this into their own
hands it was a pretty big deal in Japan
too I think that cultures are kind of
very similar cuz it's just like Korean
Japan goes back and forth for high youth
suicide yeah it's like Seoul is like
number one and then now it's like Japan
or Tokyo is number one it just keeps
going back and forth and bullying is so
ingrained into the culture because
there's a lot of hazing and the hazing
is more like it's like it's very
cliquish to so it's almost like the
fraternity kind of world to kind of put
it into comparison where once you're a
part of this group now you get like
these special things up you know but
then
the other little kids beneath you but
there's like hazing all throughout life
you haze through school you haze through
groups you haze through work through the
workplace but I remember like it even
transfers into Japanese companies in the
US where there was an incident or this
like logistics company they were
notorious for their bullying and hazing
and one of the employees hung himself
because of the bullying was so bad yeah
yeah you know they don't talk about
their problems they don't communicate so
they always try to save face by like
hiding this [ __ ] and brushing it under
and I don't think they know how to sit
down and communicate about this [ __ ]
like they're not there yet yeah cuz
everyone's like oh I went through that
and you know I came out great and like I
think it's just the process of becoming
a an adult and human being you got to
learn how to do it you know so that's
their mentality what do you think um the
the rise in suicide rate actually comes
from and I'm honestly asking here
because if it is I know for a lot of
cultures it is like in grains like I
went through that and that's you know
how we did this but now suicides on the
rise this is just because people have
seen suicide as an option before and
then they like now know that that's
something they can do to escape or has
the bullying gotten worse with like
social media and stuff like there's
truly no escape like I'm just curious I
think it's a it's a combination of multi
multiple things I can't really say one
but for example like right after World
War two and the Korean War I think
people were in survival mode so if you
hear from the older generation they're
like man we didn't have all this time to
think we were just trying to eat and
work and then there was a lot more
nationalism where everyone was on the
same page of hey we need to like rebuild
our nation and work hard and and and
create like a better society again
because it's war-torn right so then both
countries are working really hard
dedicating their lives to the workplace
and all that now they were too busy
working the generation after that and so
forth this is what I believe is that now
with the wealth and now with the freedom
and now at the time we're kind of seeing
it out here in the states to is we have
a lot of time versus our parents and
their general you know the older
generation they're they're in survival
mode they're still thinking about paying
the bills and all that stuff our
generation is more like
what is happiness what is my what is the
meaning of my life what is my purpose
how can I make an impact in the world
it's a very different concept right so
this generation also in I think
specifically in Japan in Korea there's
one test that determines the rest of
your life
right and in high school it's kind of
like the SATs or whatever but if you
fail this test then it's like you don't
get into a good university you're not
gonna work
for the handful of big corporations out
there that's it that's your class you're
gonna be a lower middle class or middle
class or whatever and there's really no
upward mobility
from that point on interesting yeah and
then I think Korea is similar in Japan
where they just have a handful of major
conglomerates that rule that area like
Korea I think they have Lotte Samsung or
whatever Japan they have like Sony and
these different old hundred-year-old
corporations
yeah yeah but but but basically it's
like that's everyone's kind of dream is
like you go to the top universities and
then you go get into one of these
conglomerates and then you work your way
up but you won't really ever be at the
top because old families run that stuff
interesting we're talking about old
guard hundreds of year old families so
it's almost like a caste system and what
still is Wow
unless you're an entrepreneur or someone
that that is you know innovating and
creating and whatever which is happening
but for most of people there it's still
that system and so when they fail this
test they go [ __ ] what do I have to live
for now and then that's how they boot
that's why they you know during test
time they jump off buildings and jump
into yeah so I think it's it's like
there's not enough opportunity for them
and they don't see that there's more
chances to life because of the way
they're taught yeah they're only taught
like you get one chance and if you fail
that then that's the rest of your life
yes do it just eat yourself to death
yeah that's the best way to do it man
I'm [ __ ] slow delicious death I mean
too much food are like starting with
fingers no I mean like with food food I
go into a night market and just start
eating snacks yep all day dude and next
thing you know you're [ __ ] 40 years
old you have a heart attack but guess
what you had diarrhea every day they're
doing
that's the way to die here yeah
it's from sad I [ __ ] though the bullying
and all these extra other things going
on it's just any extra contribution is
too much then yeah I think so
[Music]